morning I'm going to be giving the first
one on supernova why we study them so
this is sort of like the frosting and
then Danny goldstein will be giving the
cake after this which is the real guts
of how we do this so I'm going to sort
of lay the ground work for why this is
an important field this is one of my
favorite supernovae 2011 Effie and I'm
going to get to why this was important
and why sometimes real-time turnaround
doesn't work and then you have to go to
plan B so what is a supernova
it's the explosive death of a star
they're the largest explosions in the
universe they when they explode the
material is flying out of there at
appreciable fractions of the speed of
light up to a fifth the speed of light
they outshine galaxies for a few weeks
made of hundreds of billions of stars
and in one month they'll emit more
energy than our Sun does in its ten
billion year lifetime Nova means new
they were first used to describe new
stars that suddenly appeared in the
night the Chinese have a much better
moniker they called them guest stars
because they appear and they go away and
like a good guest they leave so I I
prefer guest stars super was added on by
Fritz Zwicky in 1926 when they
recognized that there was a difference
between explosions which occurred in our
galaxy which had the same apparent
brightness as some explosions which
occurred in distant galaxies and he
realized that these were dramatically
dramatically brighter and so he called
them supernovae and we've been observing
supernovae for 2,000 years and I'll show
you some of those examples momentarily
how frequent are they somewhere in the
universe there's a supernova exploding
every second in a galaxy like our Milky
Way there's one supernova per century
roughly
and typical surveys that are going on
right now generate about one to three
supernovae per night and most of these
are very dissonant they're about 1
billion light years away so here's an
example this is a supernova remnant
so the supernova went off in the year
1006 we can infer that by looking at the
velocity of the material here and then
projecting it back given the distance
and then say oh it's about a thousand
years old this was seen by observers
with their eyes in Switzerland Egypt
Iraq China Japan and North America it
cast shadows at night and was visible
during the day for several months I am
waiting for one of these to go off
during my lifetime it would be very cool
to point out to anybody walking down the
street and say hey this is what I study
this is the Crab Nebula images taken
with the Hubble Space Telescope and this
supernova went off in 1054 it was bright
enough to see during the daylight for 23
days and was visible in the night sky
for almost two years and this is
petroglyph by the Anasazi Native
Americans and this is an actual map of
where the supernova was in the sky on
July 4th 1054 that hand is to give you
an idea how far away it was from the
crescent moon at that time and that's an
actual distance away that we can project
back to that date when we knew it was
from other archives in Japan and China
when they recorded the brightness so
these are these are impressive events
when they go off in our galaxy
and these are the two coolest supernovae
because I think of it as the professor
and the student
this is Tycho Brahe he he discovered a
supernova by eye
in 1572 this is its remnant today and
then his graduate student Johannes
Kepler found his own supernova in 1604
my graduate students aren't going to be
that lucky I don't think so you know
tough for them
this is then the most impressive one I
think that's gone off during my lifetime
supernova 87 a it was visible by eye
that unfortunately you had to be in the
southern hemisphere it went off in the
Large Magellanic Cloud only a hundred
and seventy thousand light-years away
and here is an image of the supernova
expanding into a shell of material that
the star before it died threw off and
then the supernova ejecta is running
into it's slamming into it and
brightening it up and this material came
out maybe 20,000 years before the
supernova exploded we're still following
the supernova today it's easily visible
thirty years later with the Hubble Space
Telescope so there are a couple
different types of supernovae core
collapse supernovae these are massive
stars somewhere eight to ten times and
more massive and our Sun they burn
hydrogen to helium all the way down to
iron the iron core can only get so big
before the protons and electrons get
smushed together the ANU clear physics
and create neutrons collapses rapidly
down into a neutron star and then
there's some magic and we still have no
idea today exactly what goes on we
believe there's a combination of magneto
hydrodynamics the creation of all these
neutrinos when you push the protons and
electrons together to make the neutrons
and that throws off the outer layers of
the star and ends it in its explosive
death there's another type of supernova
thermonuclear supernova these we call
type 1a supernovae binary system with
some other star here and a white dwarf a
carbon-oxygen white dwarf that accretes
material over there's a limit called the
Chandrasekar limit which is basically
about
point four times the mass of our Sun as
it builds up to that limit and basically
that's the limit at which it can no
longer support itself via electron
degeneracy pressure a quirk of nuclear
physics happens the temperatures and
densities go up incredibly and you
ignite carbon and a runaway
thermonuclear explosion and so these
flow up the problem is we don't quite
know what we're we have some very good
observations that that these must be
carbon oxygen white or that there's no
other way to make them but we have very
little constraint on what's going on
here is this a star like our Sun is it
another carbon oxygen white dwarf and
they spiral in together and that gets it
about the Chandrasekar mass and and they
explode we do know that they're old in
the sense that they're seen in galaxies
which only have stars like our Sun so
they can be up to 10 billion years old
so we know their carbon oxygen white
dwarfs we know they have some other
companion but the big search now is what
exactly is the mechanism so why do we
bother studying these things so we are
star stuff okay as Carl Sagan said many
many moons ago when I was a kid
hydrogen and helium traces of lithium
maybe beryllium from the Big Bang and
then pretty much everything else gets
out through the explosion of a massive
star and more recently we know from the
recently detected binary neutron star
merger that heavier elements the
lanthanides etc are created from the
merger of two neutron stars so gold etc
platinum down on the list all the way up
to uranium interestingly to make a
binary neutron star you need two
supernova explosions to go off so you
have two massive stars orbiting each
other they both go supernova and then
eventually those two neutron stars
coalesce and explode so that's the first
part nuclear physics this is the binary
neutron star what was going on we have
some very good theoretical models that
made predictions and the first one was
seen and unfortunately was not
discovered in real time survey I think
most of the ones in the future will be
described how that will be done this was
discovered more or less by AI and we had
some great theoretical models they made
predictions as to what we would see and
the predictions actually wound up
matching the observations we hope to
catch a lot more of these so we can
understand if the one we found just a
few months ago is typical or if there's
a wide variety of these events and what
they produce cosmology this is another
reason we love studying supernovae the
type 1a supernovae that explode at the
Chandrasekar mass those supernovae are
unique because they have that trigger
they need to get up to that mass in
order to explode and because of that
they wind up being very very similar in
brightness and so we basically wind up
with what is a standard you know 18
billion Giga watt light bulb out there
that we can use to measure distances
through the inverse square law and this
was work that was done here and at
Berkeley Lab back in the late 90s and
you know we've now basically seen that
the universe is accelerating and there's
this force due to dark energy and that
was first discovered by using supernovae
as cosmic probes so back in 1998 when I
first came out to the lab we were doing
a search for supernovae on the 4 meter
telescope the victor Blanco telescope
down in the southern hemisphere this is
in Chile you can see the Southern Cross
that's Mars if you the image quality was
a little bit better we could see clouds
here this is a crisp
who was on the opposing team we weren't
goofing off that night was horrible I
think we later played basketball in the
four meter dome they had a basketball
hoop underneath it I was a much much
better player than Chris was he was on
the competing team so there was a little
bit of a rivalry there so I went up 10
points on him and then I realized that
being at 8,000 feet you know sort of
takes attacks on your body and the score
radically started shifting towards Chris
while I was just basically God I got to
take a breath
but we would go back to back over to
three nights and then they would have to
three nights and we would find
supernovae we were looking sometimes in
different parts of the sky sometimes not
so the very hands-on operation this is
sort of what it looked like down at
Sarah - Lola will we'd image with 1k by
1k or 2 K by 2 KC CDs we take 50 to 100
images across the sky we'd come back
just about a month later not quite and
we take another set of 50 to 100 images
these would be sent up to Berkeley over
what amounted to a modem a 56k baud
modem connection that was good enough to
get the data there in 24 hours we would
do image subtraction on it and then
students would and scan this data and
look for new events a galaxy with a
supernova on top of it and then one
night later we would schedule follow-up
at the Keck telescope in Hawaii and get
a spectrum to tell us is it a type 1a is
the ones we want to be standard candles
- to measure cosmology with and then
follow-up would then be triggered for
the ones we liked at the Isaac Newton
telescope on the Canary Islands the wind
telescope in Arizona or the Hubble Space
Telescope in space and we'd monitor
these for a couple months
measured the peak brightness and then do
our cosmology work with it
and this was this was basically the team
there and most of the younger people
here were the ones who were looking at
this imaging data basically not quite
blinking it but say coordinated blinking
we'd used the computers tell us where a
good bright spot was and then we'd look
at it and this is sort of what the
differencing image looks like with lots
of garbage and it was just running on a
cluster of computers nothing too
terribly fancy so there was a search for
nearby supernovae this was done
basically on photographic plates and
then ours was the first digital
supernova and we made this diagram of
brightness versus the expansion that we
measured from the galaxies and how fast
they were moving away from us and we
measured that the universe was actually
accelerating okay and so very quickly
you'll notice here that the number of
supernovae they find at low redshift was
comparable to the ones that we found in
high redshift very distant ones and this
is just a geometric effect okay I do
something like this with my detector I
have one person here in the front row
and six or seven of you in the back row
it's easier to find things farther away
with the given detector and so we
rapidly realized that you know even if
we just continued on nothing new changes
to our detectors whatever at high
redshift we would start to dwarf the
number of supernovae that we had nearby
that we need to anchor what we call the
Hubble diagram here and so this became
our challenge is how do we increase the
number of supernovae there at at low
redshift so this is everybody at the
2011 Nobel Prize ceremony won by Saul
Perlmutter Bren Schmidt and Adam riess
we all wore our penguin suits and at
that time we were in the middle of
really pushing both high redshift doing
new searches with the Hubble Space
Telescope
but going after much much better ways to
get low redshift supernovae because this
was our biggest challenge in terms of
making a finer measurement so this is
sort of what real supernova detection
looks like and this is what Danny is
going to talk about is how what is the
math and and what are the algorithms
behind it but per image 2 K by 2 K image
we'd have about 200 5 Sigma detections
so this is something you can't see by
eye you know just in a single this is
the new image this is the reference
image you subtract the new from the ref
you see the supernova you can't see that
without doing the image subtraction but
the image subtraction it sticks out
pretty well here though is a piece of
garbage this is a star that saturated in
one image didn't saturate in the other
left some residual looks like garbage
here's another one because the star
actually moved stars move that sucks so
we put a lot of cuts in and then like I
said we triggered basically a human to
look at the position where those cuts
were made Danny is going to talk about
how we took that to the next level and
automated it but we were only taking say
100 images a night we had 200 5 Sigma
candidates it's 20,000 objects ok we'd
cut through them with some cuts maybe
get it down to 10,000 we had 10 students
so each of them look at a thousand
objects takes you about five seconds to
look under an object you can rip through
this in a few hours and that's the way
we were back then and that's what we did
we just brought in students the problem
was when we started to work on the
nearby soup searches and so these are
the first three searches that were done
one was done at Haleakala on the 1.2
meter telescope and then there were two
successive surveys with different
instruments on the Palomar telescopes
but just start looking at the data here
instead of doing you know
five ten minute exposures on a to K by
2k CCD we had 4k by 4k see CDs and we
were doing twenty second exposures okay
and the rates of data started increasing
dramatically to twelve gigabytes a night
to twenty eight gigabytes a night when
we got over here on the second iteration
of the Palomar telescope and this was
just a huge years later five you know
five to three to five years later in
2001 and okay you still get the same
number of false positives okay per it's
it's a pixel star thing it's not because
we're staring deeper we saw more of
these things we get the same 200 per
image that we took and so multiply this
up okay doing a thousand square degrees
a night this was a 250 times increase in
scale per night and by the way we'd run
this survey every single night it wasn't
like we'd go out and observe in October
come back in November and then do our
follow-up from December to January this
was find a supernova
tonight start following it with this
telescope find a supernova tomorrow
night followed up boom boom boom so this
was constant
this is where we really had to start
getting clever and for awhile we did it
with humans and then as Danny will show
in the next talk how we got around this
the other interesting thing was
bandwidth data transfer I had a
professor in graduate school who said
never underestimate the bandwidth of a
station wagon filled with that tapes and
there is something to that actually when
we were doing this survey in 2000 down
at the telescope in Arizona we would
take a raid array of disks we had three
of them
they each had about five terabyte
capacity at that time very expensive and
we'd have one down at the telescope one
at the lab and one in transit via FedEx
and then later we switched to another
thing should have seen him after two
years they were dented on the sides and
every
but it could get back to the lab in less
than 24 hours and we just plug it in to
our cluster and start doing the search
okay
things had to change as we moved forward
and then this was the big change the one
in 2011 is telling you we were neck deep
in at the at the Nobel ceremony there we
were still worrying about this and so
Pete Palomar transient factory is the
one I'm going to talk about it just
finished up in 2017 in the spring we're
getting ready for a new survey now which
by the way just I heard last night made
its first extra galactic supernova
discovery which was just confirmed it's
as wiki transient facility I'll show you
where we're going with that in the near
future but to show how different this is
you know we had a seven-point eight
square degree field of view I'll show
you what that looks like we were taking
one-minute exposures and then we started
cranking on this in 2009 and we had two
Cadence's we did one where we were
searching every night sort of where the
faster transients may be in nearby
galaxies clusters only you know 60 100
million light years away and then a
survey that sort of went on three to
five day time scales covering a good
like large chunks of the sky down at
Palomar in the mountains between LA and
San Diego the 48-inch was our discovery
engine and then as dick mentioned we
want to feed other telescopes with
real-time discovery and the 60 inch was
one of the main drivers there in terms
of finding things here and then as
quickly as we could pushing them over
there
FedEx no longer going to work so there
is this network down there called HP
wren set up to basically
provide networking services to the
Native Americans who had their schools
and such here I'll describe actually
what their bandwidth is mostly used for
later and microwave relay towers that go
over the mountains and then down to San
Diego and so Palomar is here we
piggybacked off of this network sent it
down to San Diego supercomputing Center
and then it came up on the network here
- yes now so this is what the camera
looks like there was one dead ship
here's the size of the full moon so you
can see how big a chunk of the sky we're
doing the camera has one arcsecond
resolution that's about the size of a
dime at one mile so it's a fairly
impressive resolution and like I said
taking 60 second exposures it gets down
to twenty first magnitude that's about a
million times less right than you can
see with your eye okay so that's sort of
the depth of the faintest objects that
you can see on here by the way when
you're looking at these the majority of
the smudges that you see there are
actually galaxies they're not stars and
so this gives you an idea of how we can
get up to a rate of one supernova three
supernova a night if one supernova blows
off per century in the Milky Way galaxy
if we look at 100 galaxies we'll see one
a year if we look at 10,000 and skaldak
seas we'll see one a night okay so
that's sort of the statistics that were
we're dealing with so we had to look at
sort of that number of galaxies per
night now there are a whole bunch of
different science projects it wasn't
just supernovae that was a good chunk of
it but people were looking at other
types of odd things that would blow up
cataclysmic variables people wanted to
study variable stars you know measure
their like curved shapes people wanted
to follow up
black holes that all of a sudden sucked
in a nearby star gas and exploded people
were looking at near-earth objects etc
the cool thing about this is we all work
together and our follow-up programs will
all coordinated since if you see a
smudge of life if you don't know exactly
what it is right it could be something
very distant
it could be something nearby just a long
line of sight you don't know so all of
the groups would pull together follow-up
time from all of these different
telescopes to trigger on these events in
real time and so as a community we
worked on these problems together and
this was the real power of the entire
program was the ability to trigger on
this follow up in real time and the
closer to real time as I'll explain in
the second half of my talk the better
okay if you looked at the cost of the
serial the maintenance of the telescope
and running the operations was about 25%
of the total budget another 25% went
into the computing and the algorithms
and the interface to set it up and to
find these things rapidly and to
turnaround on it and then half of it
went into the follow-up telescopes so if
you're trying to use your money
effectively what you don't want to do is
give these guys bad things to follow up
because that's where you're spending
your most bucks so that's what we looked
upon in terms of operations and in terms
of writing our algorithms is how do we
optimize the science that these guys are
triggering on so this is sort of the
workflow that we have we take the data
at the 48-inch
comes down in the microwave relay and
then to es net and then came to the
National Energy Research supercomputing
Center just up on the hill there through
a data transfer node we would do image
processing to trending so you get a raw
image you'd have to take off the bias
there's a flat field
you do that you'd solve for how deep the
image was where their clouds at night
etc you you solve for things like that
then you run the image subtraction you
even might stack the data and then you
do things like create a reference image
if you haven't had one already solve for
the Strama tree in there to line up the
two images so that you could run the
image subtraction and then we go through
basically what what Danny is going to
talk about is how to identify in the sea
of junk basically a million objects
tonight we would find of those basically
a thousand were interesting
Astrophysical transients and of those
one of them was a new transient okay so
it's a one in a million
type thing that's what goes on here but
we also compare to known stars or
asteroids and then we have triggers
there were triggers that would wake
somebody up there were triggers that
would automatically salute with
telescope without human interaction etc
and we got these triggers down to about
40 minutes in our first pass with the
Palomar transient factory okay
and so here again here's a typical image
you can see all the garbage check there
this is the only interesting object and
so like I said sort of a
one-in-a-million type thing this is what
we wound up doing in the Palomar
transient Factory we took one point
eight two million objects in a red band
and in a green bluer band took about a
few hundred thousand made over a million
and a half subtractions we had coverage
almost on the entire northern sky that
you could see from Palomar we had about
a billion candidates in our database but
of those that were interesting just just
below 50,000 and this was done in eight
hundred and fifty one nights so this is
how we started off we were running it on
a IBM I did
flex machine called Carver we had a very
generous donation from nurse to work on
one of the first real-time pipelines
that they had there we had real-time
cues that we could send into to run on
and we basically filled up this entire
space and we had a database that was
about a terabyte by the time we were
done sitting on one of these science
gateway nodes eventually this pipeline
was replicated by three other surveys
Danny will talk about one of the other
ones the dark energy survey that that
used this pipeline to great success up
there
so this back in 2012 Josh and I were
observing at Keck one night and we
weren't in Hawaii we were actually just
sitting about 300 yards over there in
the basement of Campbell Hall and we
said you know what we were doing things
with about 24-hour turnaround and we
said why don't we try to do something in
the night so we can slough and look at
something with the Keck telescope at
night that's it's a great thing we had
about three hours time delay so sky
swings around 24 hours the difference
between Palomar and Hawaii is about
three hours so that gave us a three hour
window to find something in Palomar and
then it would be directly overhead by
the time we were on it Keck so what we
did was start to push the pipeline in by
hand so I talked to the people at nurse
got some cues up Josh was there with his
machine learning algorithms that Danny
will talk about and we just started
sitting there and doing it in real time
and we triggered on the supernova that
actually wound up being one of the
youngest supernovae that we we ever
caught to that point and that's where we
said we have to automate this and so we
we automated it and I would say about
three months later we had it running at
where most of the candidates from the
time the shutter closed at Palomar
the time we had a candidate in the
database and we could do something
actionable with it like trigger another
telescope or wake somebody up to take a
look at it or more likely alert our
European collaborators who were in the
middle of their day was about one hour
for the worst-case and median turnaround
time was about thirty minutes and so we
had a bunch of discoveries that kept on
pushing us to younger and younger times
so when the Palomar transient factories
shut down in December of 2012 they
started a program called the
intermediate Palomar transient factory
or the interim Palomar trans in factory
I don't know it was the bridge between
the Palomar transient actory in the
zookie transient facility and I took
everything offline for one month we
rewrote the entire pipelines and we
pushed it through there was a nice
project on the idea we called extreme
scale scientific workflow analysis and
prediction we use them to basically go
through and do everything from
understanding our file systems database
queries etc parallelizing our codes and
now you can see the time in seconds and
this is a logarithmic scale we were
doing basically everything in five
minutes so we instrumented our pipeline
for timings this was the most important
part every single step there about 39
steps we had a painting to the database
to say it took this long to do this we
got to where you're running several of
these simultaneously we knew more about
the nurse center than they did in real
time we were querying some part of the
nurse center from data transfer to file
system IO to how quickly a job started
up on the real-time queuing system every
quarter of a second okay throughout the
entire night we fix things like how long
it took to load Python from their
libraries who looked at and said this is
ridiculous it's taking 60 seconds to
load it up
they realized that there was an error in
the way that they put the libraries into
their system
we moved all of the i/o to a luster
scratch file system that made it much
much better we optimized our databases
up the wazoo
and then this guy yi Kao he was the one
who did it I basically gave him a list I
said here take my old horrible pipeline
that was written in bash Perl Fortran
C++ I had some other languages in there
oh there was Java there was some Josh's
Python and I said just redo everything
in Python with calls to some C libraries
he did that we tweaked up our database
he got it he got it going great
he got this East science fellowship at
u-dub and he was gonna start working on
LSST and then Google set them up just
like that and he's like well they
offered me 2x my salary and stock
options what should I do and I'm like
what do you think he'll be happy doing
and he's like well I have a daughter now
and I'm like okay take the job if that's
what you want and and he's been there
now just over a year and he tells me
he's very happy he's working in a
research center and and enjoying it
quite well okay so this is a list of all
the things that we did with these 39
check points so this is what it looks
like this is just one of the checkpoints
how long does it take to transfer data
from the telescope up to nurse and
you'll notice that it takes longer at
the start of the night this is around 7
o'clock at night and then that speeds up
and then in the morning it kicks up so I
had the folks
yes net do an analysis of the network
and say hey what's going on what is the
traffic on the HP Ren network that that
causes the slowdowns here and here but
things are relatively smooth and they
said well you know at first guests
before you even looking at my guess is
this is most people coming home
and and you know looking at news and
things like that and then here they're
waking up in the morning and they're
doing some stuff and then during the
middle of the night turns out almost all
of this traffic right here is from the
Indian gambling casinos that are in the
mountains outside of Palomar and this
they identified the bulk of the slowdown
was due to horse racing in China that
they would livestream at the casinos so
people could bet on okay and I was just
stunned but okay so we did not file any
official things because they're allowed
to use it whatever way they want to use
it but this does allow you to think
about how you optimize your survey if
you know it's going to take a hundred
and sixty seconds to transfer an image
here maybe you do fields which don't
require as much real-time turnaround as
say a field you can do here so say the
people that want to just characterize
variable stars they go up and down and
up and down they just want good coverage
they're not reacting to anything okay
they just they just want the statistics
so you look at the galaxy at the
beginning part of the night and then you
look at the extra galactic fields during
the middle of the night where you have
supernovae where you want to turn around
immediately so optimizations were put in
to do some things like this with the
survey in the last year we started to
look at things like the number of
candidates divided by the time that it
took to process them versus the median
time and and what we noticed is the more
candidates that you had on an image the
longer it took to process this is not
surprising every candidate you have to
query the database see what was there
before you have to run more machining
learn machine learning algorithms on it
etc so this trend wasn't so surprising
and a lot of this can be paralyzed but
it was this trend why do we get these
several Sigma outliers that take so much
longer almost all of this was due to
glitches at nurse things like there was
some issue with the IO system or there
was some networking issue and would
cause three Forex delays in what we were
expecting so you know we put some
uncertainties on this and then when we
got any of these that would come up
during the survey we'd send a message to
nurse look at the check point and say oh
this is a networking type issue this is
a processing type issue this is a
filesystem issue and just send them a
little notice and then if we look you
know this is another way of looking at
that and you can see the the the
outliers here and now we're working on a
project with them because they're moving
to the idea of having a super facility
the idea of running workflows like this
in real time they want to know about
these issues so they're teaming up with
us to work on a project where they can
understand these outliers see how
they're responsible for it and then work
to tweak up the system to to mitigate
this to provide a certain level of
surface for real-time analysis so this
is what we wound up doing at the end of
these two surveys we identified over
3000 and typed them spectroscopically
supernova we had hundred thousand
galactic transients and tens of
thousands of transients in our nearest
neighbor and thirty-one these are the
images we took we tended to stay away
from the galaxy until the last few years
that's the galaxy here and of course we
can't see down in the south
but these are the number of images going
up from the orangish which is about ten
to the white which is about a thousand
that we took over a hundred and ninety
publications seven in nature and three
in science since 2009 so it's quite a
successful survey
so here are some of the science things
that we were able to glean out of the
program so one of the things if you find
a supernova you might ask yourself what
happened before the supernova went off
so we got a supernova we saw these
hydrogen lines in the supernova that
suggested it was running into something
that was out there question is when did
that something out there go off we went
back in the data so this is sort of our
limiting brightness this is time and you
know here was our first detection and
then the supernova screamed up and we
went back and we stacked images from
earlier and we found pre outbursts that
went on and and this was actually the
star undergoing some mash Nations where
it's lopped off some of its atmosphere
and threw it out at several hundred
kilometers per second right before the
supernova explosion we now think this
happens in most of the massive stars
sort of in the 20 solar mass range that
this is happening more often than not so
now one of the things that we decided to
do was let's add in another type of
image processing which is we'll take all
the images from the week stack them
together to go deeper so that we could
go down and detect these things so that
we could see a little burr so while we
had the supernova and we could take
spectra here it would be really cool if
we could have found it back here when it
had one of these pre outbursts so we
could study the exact nature of that pre
outbursts in a lot better detail so now
we're running two pipelines we take data
for a week we stack it we look for
things and then we run the nightly one
on top of it and we try to do things
that way and so this is sort of the
schematic of what was going on with this
supernova supernova blows up there's a
cloud it it lights it up making all
these hydrogen lines and then everyone
into it we have these things called
gamma-ray bursts gamma ray bursts some
chunk of them come from supernova that
produced Jets and create strong beams of
light
unfortunately gamma rays are hard to
detect you know they basically have
these box like detectors four of them on
a spacecraft they get hit by gamma rays
they sort of triangulate back sometimes
they can do this very well and like
precision down to I can point any
telescope in the world at it and
sometimes they just basically tell you
yeah it's somewhere up there okay and so
you have to go searching this is one of
the searches that we did for one of
those ones where it wasn't what we call
well localize and so you can see the
images that we took and then we saw this
transient go off in this field and we
want to get on these very quickly
because these things drop like a rock in
brightness if we were 24 hours later no
chance of seeing this and on top of that
you're gonna find so many transients in
these fields the one characteristic
about these is that they're dropping
quickly during the night whereas almost
all the other transients they'll they'll
be bright they might change by 5 or 10%
but they're not going to drop by a
factor too so not only do you want to
hit this once you want to hit it several
times and watch this thing go down and
so that's what we were able to do
another one came along and so now we are
quite good at this and our next survey
is going to really be using this where
things are poorly localized from other
areas of Astrophysical searching we can
do follow-up in pinpoint these these
after blows orphan after glows these are
basically gamma-ray bursts for which
there was no detection of gamma rays ok
this can happen for a couple reasons one
the gamma ray signal is not strong
enough and the other is that that
spacecraft or spacecrafts aren't looking
in that
portion of the sky they can't cover
everything okay and so here you can see
how rapidly these are falling in
brightness each magnitude is a factor of
2.5 in brightness so just over the
course of a half a day
this is dropping by almost a factor of
10 and this is what it looks like
there's nothing there's something ok and
you go and you look in deep images you
can barely see anything and then we take
a spectrum of this and this was
incredibly high redshift this is almost
8 billion light years away
it's a gamma-ray burst pointed at us ok
flash spectroscopy there are some
interesting supernovae and this was one
of them we found a few of these now so
you have a whole bunch of non detection
x' and then boom you see the supernova
and during the same night it screams up
in brightness and we were able to get a
spectrum just a few hours later at Keck
and then we started triggering follow up
on all of these different instruments so
this is the number of hours so we took
an image here we wait 45 minutes and we
take another image we use that to rule
out asteroids because asteroids will
move we take two images if it's at the
same location we're pretty sure it's not
an asteroid second image comes in then
we have an automated trigger
we took a spectrum just a few hours
later at Keck and then we started
triggering the Swift Space Telescope
follow-up from the ground from the Las
Cumbres Observatory the VLA and the very
large array of radio telescopes on the
Carmen telescope and all of these were
triggered within eight hours of
detection and this is what we saw we saw
a spectrum very early on that looked
like a star spectrum a star that has a
very very quick wind these are called
Wolff ray stars here are a whole bunch
of different models actually these are
actual observations and different
wolf-rayet stars and then this is the
spectrum that we got so we could
actually see what type of star exactly
this was and they're like a supernova
explosion why would we
see that what it was was the supernova
was very far down there was this wind
that was out there and the supernova
just acted like a light bulb and just
lit up the surrounding guest so that we
could see it we can see what was there
and then what happened was that
supernova ejecta starts expanding and
now it's becoming a substantial fraction
of the brightness of the object there
and it starts to dominate the spectrum
you can see some of the lines now are
just you know fading away you can barely
detect it just a few hours later and
then finally the supernova sweeps over
all that material and all you can see is
the supernova and it's high-velocity
material and that's it so these are
observations that only exist for the
first 12 hours and it points back
directly to what type of star blew up so
so quite important quite quick
turnaround observations to get so this
is one of my favorite ones where the
pipelines entirely screwed up so we were
doing a survey in the Bloor bands a GV &
run is only about 500 square degrees hit
twice during the night and it was split
half and half between the nightly
cadence and these three to five decades
we found ten new transients that night
and unfortunately the supercomputing
Center updated the kernel on all their
machines during the night and didn't
tell me
and so the pipeline completely failed
because I had to recompile all the code
so I recompile the code at about 6 a.m.
and then started up the pipeline and
things started going through and then
there was another problem at Caltech
they just changed an IP address and and
we couldn't have this automatic saving
so we had to save things by hand and so
what do two young people do like Josh
and myself we start looking at things
that the Machine tells us to look at and
we start saving my hand and Josh found
this beautiful one
then you subtract off the eight hours so
you can see what time of day we were
doing it and he said woohoo look at that
awesome and then I found this one right
here and I said I see your 20 and raise
you 100 and this was the supernova
if you zoom out so when I showed on the
very first slide 2011 Fe it was caught
about a hundred times a hundred thousand
times fainter than the eye can see there
was a 20% rise in the first two
detection separated by one hour so we
knew we caught it very young and it was
caught at one one thousandth the
brightness that it would reach when it
finally hit peak brightness we sent out
a telegram just a few hours after that
we were able to slew a telescope in the
Canary Islands to get a spectrum just
before the just literally after sunset
on the Canaries we got this one in and
we sent out an alert and pretty much
every major observatories started
following up this super nila so not
quite real-time but close so here's the
night nice image
this supernova is still being followed
even to the state with the Hubble Space
Telescope we were able to divine from
those very early observations and non
detection that we had the night before
but the only thing small enough to
produce that was a carbon-oxygen white
dwarf something we assumed many years do
the nuclear physics do the materials
that were burned we were able to say the
only star that could basically cause
this supernova was a carbon oxygen
weight or here's another thing
gravitational wave this is all the rage
with LIGO the gravitational wave
detector here is one of the issues it's
very similar to the poorly localized
gamma inverse issue is that the
gravitational wave detectors even with
three of them online right now sort of
give you a chunk of sky maybe 100 square
degrees 200 squared
in which you have transients this was
the first one black hole black hole
merger we weren't expected to see
anything we still went after it you can
see here are all the supernovae that we
actually found had nothing to do with
the gravitational wave trigger but so
these are sort of one-in-a-million type
objects you've got to wade through all
of these before you actually see
something that you would expect so it
requires paving over the sky and I'll
talk about how we'll do that so sifting
through all of these getting rapid
spectroscopic follow up so we could
characterize it and just basically
finding a bunch of supernovae so let me
skip through so this is where we're up
to Zwicky transient facilities so this
is PTF this is one you've probably heard
about LSST this is the size of those
wiki transient facilities it's a 47
square degree imager it's absolutely
huge if you compare it to PTF it is more
than an order of magnitude tester
they'll be taking 30-second exposures
instead of 60 they have 47 square
degrees instead of seven and so it will
just basically it runs out of sky before
it runs out of time okay so they will
basically be observing the entire extra
galactic sky every three nights and and
that's what's going on with this imager
they just started observations so this
is one of the issues that we'll have
with ztf to some level but we're
definitely going to have what they'll
SST so this is for me an absolutely
boring transient goes up and down some
variable star okay and these are non
detection upper limits on how deep our
survey can go so we're not finding this
object at all here okay and and these
limits go up and down and their gaps
between them because we have weather so
that will block out some observations
while clouds sometimes more often than
not
have the moon the moon makes the sky
brighter it's harder to see things so we
don't go as deep and then all of a
sudden we get over to this area here and
you know we start seeing it and and our
first two detections are actually going
to show something on the rise and the
question for us is this something which
is interesting or is it some boring
stupid star that's just going up and
down okay and so what we want to do is
avoid the problem safe for LSST where
we're paving over the sky going through
all this data and we're finding
something so incredibly faint because
instead of being a 48 inch telescope
this is an 8 meter telescope and the
only thing we can follow up is a 30
meter telescope we want to avoid that
okay so how many triggers can we handle
and how can we optimize our follow-up is
is our big challenge okay and and so
this for me is is it you have this
firehose of data and you're taking a hit
off of it and you want to do this in the
optimized way so Danny's going to talk
about the machine learning and and how
we trigger on that and I'll move this
because I've seen people go into
epileptic seizures watching this video
so I'll move it off of that back to this
but we have this data stream coming out
so not only do we want to tell if it's
one of these one-in-a-million events but
we want to characterize it beyond that
is this a boring one-in-a-million event
or is it an interesting one in a million
event and so then what we have to do is
go back and trigger our pipeline to
search at a deeper level say run stacks
you know at finer cadence longer cadence
say is this something that's going up
and down use data from other surveys in
real time to tell us oh do we have
imaging from something that's you know a
thousand times deeper so we can see is
it a star is it a galaxy what what is
this is it interesting to us those are
the challenges that we face and what
that's going to do is create a feedback
loop and if you do the math on it that
feedback loop becomes as important if
more important than what we're doing in
real time in terms of the amount of data
that you're going through and the amount
of processing so our next stop in this
is you're going to see the bulk of the
machinery under this and how we find
things with the machine learning the
next challenge for us is how do we take
that to the next level maybe apply
machine learning to it to understand
that cheat back loop and what we want to
go after in there so so here's my
typical so I work for the Department of
Energy subcontracted through UC so why
is do-e interested in this well do e is
the largest funder of science in the
United States I do a modified version of
weapons physics okay
I study explosive transients I do
radiation hydrodynamic modeling of these
type of transients my graduate students
have gone on to work in industry they've
gone on to work in academia they've gone
on to work at the weapons labs this
benefits them quite directly they need
these people okay do e has always been
interested in fundamental physics
understanding parameters from high
energy physics nuclear physics etc we do
the same thing just in a different way
through astrophysics so that's how we
justify our do-e slice of the funding is
we're doing fundamental research and
then we provide benefits that go back
into the weapons program that go back
into industry the people the to students
I have that are now working for Google
they're doing things that involve
machine learning real-time analysis and
feedback loops and pipelines
that they worked on in grad school so
it's more cynical sense okay yeah you
have something people in mind about what
what you learn Oh personally so I am
open to learning about anything that
goes bump in the night I want to
understand the universe at a very
fundamental level and explosions are
neat I've always liked them when I was a
little kid I loved blowing up stuff so
studying the biggest explosions in the
universe has always been you know a
great driver
there is nothing I and Josh will tell
you this when we were looking at the
data coming off the telescope and
looking at there's nothing neater than
seeing something that nobody else has
seen before
and then when you do follow up on it and
you find a new phenomena which nobody
has seen before that's what drives me to
understand the universe of that
fundamental level so that's that's my
motivation know one of the bottlenecks
in the in the work flow that you have
that are preventing you from seeing all
that you want to see or inferring all
that when it's there is it bottlenecks
or missed events that you're worried I
mean are there missed events because of
that so it's mostly the next survey ztf
we will not be able to look at
everything spectroscopically that we
find we did three thousand over seven
years roughly so that's a few hundred a
year okay we're gonna find a few
thousand a year so what we want to do is
use that expensive follow-up time do not
miss out on anything that's interesting
so we have something that rises gets
brighter starts falling we want to
trigger on that that describes almost
every Astrophysical transient how do we
use that basic information with maybe
other surveys telling us what's going on
in sky to say that's true
interesting or not and do it in a
statistical way so that we can say we
didn't miss anything or we miss
something and then you also want to
throw in sort of a randomized follow-up
so that you understand any of your
biases and whatever algorithm you wrote
to say trigger or not trigger because I
can only do it on 10% of the objects
that I can find whereas here we did it
about on 90% of the things that we found
how do we find those little gold nuggets
out of everything that's that's our big
challenge now we just we we now own 65%
of one of the follow-up telescopes we're
trying to decide right now what is the
algorithm that goes in there to trigger
something what is the prioritization
based upon the knowledge of the light
curve and the various groups and their
science goals how do we melt and that's
a really challenging question because
one of the great things that we can do
out of this is that when you're done
doing the survey you can go back and say
what are the rates of certain types of
objects these are really important if
you want to understand nucleosynthesis
and where did the gold come from in the
universe well you need to know the rates
of the events that produce gold and so
therefore you need to have an unbiased
sort of systematic survey which you can
regenerate populate it with those types
of explosions see how many you found see
how many there should have been and
calculate the rates I'd like to do that
and know I haven't screwed something up
so not to anthropomorphize too much but
wondering about the sort of local and
non-local effects of these things I mean
if you're a carbon-based life of
life-form that depends on those carbon
bonds sort of being intact for for
generations and generations how close do
you want to want to not be to one of
these and then again there is this
mixing over time where iron like
elements seem to it have coalesced
enough and spread around enough to have
it at the center of our planets so to
have two interesting thoughts on that
the first is there are certain types
of supernovae that you really just don't
want going off in your galaxy and so so
the anthropic principle states that
perhaps we're in a good spot because
we're far out from the center and that
those types of supernovae and most
supernovae blow up more towards the core
of our galaxy so there's something to be
there these supernovae create sort of
death rays that go across maybe half the
galaxy there are these the ones that
produce gamma-ray bursts you don't want
to be in that cone of light that comes
out there but we even calculated and
this was with one of the climate
scientists before climate was something
no longer study at do we wanted to study
the effect of nearby supernova explosion
on the Earth's atmosphere and how that
would affect it if you take one of the
nearest stars that we know will go
supernova it's Betelgeuse in Orion the
one with the belt okay
the bright red star on the shoulder
that's going to go supernova it will
actually be somewhere around half the
brightness of the minute that's about
one of the closest stars that we know
that will go supernova that's not going
to have a real effect on us but if a
star went off that was say the distance
just Sirius that would basically destroy
life as we know it on this planet so
what being Detroit
a less catastrophic question it seems
like you're on the verge of a
predicament where you're actually
solving what used to be called the
secretary problem where you not only
have to try to pick up the most
interesting events but you have to have
in mind the fact that there may be a
more interesting one coming and you
should pass this one by yep and wait for
the best one it's like waiting for the
best wave when you're surfing exactly
the problem literally as I was walking
over I was doing a teleconference this
morning which was the following and and
so I'll phrase it exactly in those terms
we have some very interesting what we
call t oo candidates these will come in
from other surveys like LIGO the
gravitational wave survey like the
gamma-ray burst their unload eyes dwell
have to move slew the telescope cover
that portion of the sky and then trigger
follow-up on those events and then we
have the generic ones that we find and
we want to do a census of these to get
our rates and do those well so I
proposed this morning that well the
people from the T oh oh you know and we
only have so many hours on the night
that we can do it and it's not enough to
do everything so a solution that I'm
throwing out there now but I'd love to
hear from you guys as to better ones
because there was a large argument this
morning
and I said I'll come up with an
algorithm this week so maybe somebody
can help me with this I said the tos
have sort of a prediction for how many
events they'll see on order once a week
way of course statistics being what they
are sometimes you'll get three sometimes
you get four what I'm worried about is
the cuts that they've put in there are
going to create 10 or 20 of these events
and now they'll start running into our
census and they'll so what I suggested
was well they have some certain rate
let's handle a 3 Sigma bump over a week
but over the month they should get
allocated the time that they should and
so we'll give them a priority that's in
proportion
to the time that they've used already
maybe waited in a way over the months
okay so yeah they could be the highest
priority during the week if they haven't
had anything they'll go in immediately
if they're on their fourth trigger for
the week well then they'll fall down
into the and so we're trying to weight
that right now and we're trying to
weight the goals of doing the census
survey over the whole sky down to a
certain brightness level and how do you
optimize that so that's that is a real
real question for us now and we don't
know the best way to solve it but there
is a heuristic if you're looking for the
best event yeah and events that you
should wait you should let n over e Pass
Bobby okay and then take the best one
you see after that this is Christmas no
guarantee that it's just it's Nate
maximizes your probability ability of
getting aa boy that would be really
really disturbing if I said yeah we're
gonna skip the first and ovary event
sorry Muncie we're not gonna trigger on
your gravitational waves until we're
really sure yeah okay
well that I can propose that I think oh
my god yeah you know ultimately it's the
metric that I think everyone's China
searched for here is your because you're
talking right the N over eight probably
makes sense if you only have you know
one one bullet in the gun to pull but
what happens is you have all these
bullets throughout the night so you've
got a telescope night waiting to do
follow-up and if you don't use it you've
lost it then there's very expensive
follow-up resources like at the
Space Telescope level or the Keck
telescope level where you do only have a
few you know kits that you can call in
if you use that and you don't get good
science out of it eventually that winds
up coming to to haunt you there so
there's the optimization metric over
there like the rum spelly and you know
known unknowns butter but then there's
that other dimension which Pierre is
alluding to in these very large surveys
which is it's not Peter that's gonna
make the optimization metric over his
science the whole survey itself is
beholdin because it has federal funding
to put out a whole number of transients
which people within a given group may
not be interested in but another group
may be very interested in right so
there's a lot of garbage in our solar
system for instance like asteroids that
nobody in or very few people in his ETF
collaboration care about but there's a
whole cohort of people around the world
that do and there's certain types of
asteroids that matter a whole lot and
need very rapid follow-up so there's
this interesting problem now where
there's so much data and each person or
each group has their own optimization
metric and how you allow each of them to
basically you know Blom that on to a
survey and and the other challenge is
some of them know the rates of their
objects very very well these been
studied for a while they know the
uncertainties to ten percent okay and
others sort of have like a factor two
and that needs to be folded into this
follow-up as well is that they can't be
dominating the time because their
science is not as interesting as a whole
as all the other science that we could
do with these resources as well so
that's the other challenge that we have
when you take a group of picture
this guy is there a way to use
probability to say okay we really need
to take one-third of the pictures and we
should be able to get that at that point
so take so the answer is yes if you are
following up sort of the standard known
type of explosions I can do that I could
make people happy that would work if you
want to find incredibly young things and
that goes out the door
I literally have to come back every few
hours and hit that part of the sky
because my window of opportunity is just
a few hours and so I'll miss it you know
so so yes some of the survey can be
optimized that way but other parts of it
know we just have to do the whole sky
this guy is something might interesting
might happen I can predict portions of
the sky where some things won't be
interesting for me which is basically
staring at our galaxy but no
unfortunately these are totally chaotic
random events and no yeah
that's we unless it's unless it's what
Danny will mention there there is one
type of object that when we see one
we have a very good idea when the second
one wall
all this optimization to attractive
events that have a specific
characteristic that you come to expect
is there much room for discovering you
know events of the kind that you haven't
classified so far so this this is the
real challenge that we want to make
whatever our algorithm that goes in
there you almost want to randomly then
one out of 50 events just select
something throw it in and do it and and
just just to understand are we missing
stuff that yeah we need to do I don't
know if I noticed a a true bitbucket
namely data that is thrown away really
thrown away or not
nothing is stirring the wacko so that is
one thing where we are different than a
lot of other of the groups that have
stuff is that every pixel that we've
ever taken is important because we want
to go back historically say what
happened there to find pre outbursts we
want to go back historically to make a
deeper image by stacking many images to
see if this is a boring transient that's
just going up and down and we just
happen to catch it over here in a
slightly brighter face so we just never
throw away anything to do that all the
time and that is a huge huge area going
back looking at the data set saying
we've done this right now the first
binary neutron star merger we never knew
what they look like we had theoretical
predictions I did not even know it's my
former grad student I did not trust it
well enough to say let's optimize a
survey to find these things okay once
they found it oh now we know what they
look like I can go back through the
entire pipeline and say anything else in
there that was sort of down in the weeds
that look like this I can dig a little
deeper we found one object that sort of
looks like that and so that is a very
interesting
because one plus or minus one doesn't
tell you huge amount of things about the
rates but two plus or minus root two
tells you a little bit more so okay you
are dismissed for cookies and tea